hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to until dawn a brand new
triple a
horror game that is supposed to be very
good and where your choices
actually matter now whether that
actually comes into play in the game we
will find out
but when i loaded up this game it jump
scared me
a tiny butterfly flapping its wings
today may lead to a devastating
hurricane weeks from now
okay you can say what you want about the
truth of the butterfly effect but this
game
is supposed to be about that the
smallest decision can dramatically
change the future and what that means is
that
when i'm playing
that that's what it is your actions will
shape how the story unfolds
and that's what makes this such an
interesting let's play game
because hot damn that's my story but
your joe
is one of many possibilities how many
i don't know if i know what i'm doing
choose your actions carefully okay
that's what makes this such an
interesting let's play potential type
game because i remember hearing about
this game about a year ago
and then it kind of dropped off the face
of the earth and then it was released a
couple days ago
so not much i can say about that hello
hello sassy lady how you doing
and of course it's next-gen so it looks
good
can't tell you how long it's been since
i played a game that looks good
hello oh no is it the typical party
scene oh my god i can't believe you
actually did this
don't you guys think this is a little
bit oh come on
she deserves it it is not her fault that
she has a huge question
hannah's been making moves on him i'm
just looking out for my girl and
ah just because he's class prez doesn't
mean he belongs to everyone
mike is my man hey emily i'm not
anybody's man whatever you say darling
it seems like a super campy 80s horror
movie and i love it
because i actually enjoy those very much
so
i mean admittedly i have no idea what
this game is about i know
that's not good oh
mike it's hannah
hi mike oh okay oh am i playing now
oh god i thought i was gonna go on an
interactive date with mike
mike looked handsome
hello okay hey
did you see that no it said it'd just be
us this weekend
uh josh
am i oh i'm playing now okay god damn
it's like heavy rain
geez all sudden i'm playing as a girl in
yoga pants why not
you guys passed out drunk what kind of
party did i miss when i was staring out
the window into nothingness
hello mike mike the
guy every girl seems to be so interested
in
anybody what am i doing god damn this
game looks good by the way i just gotta
admit it looks
really really good and considering it's
all real time is more impressive than
you know anything else then again i
haven't played many uh like next-gen
titles i mean the most recent one that i
played on the ps4 was bloodborne oh no
oh
hey objects that glint can be inspected
oh like oh wait hey over here hello
press and hold to pick up the bottle wow
this is definitely heavy rain inspired
is it made by the same company i have no
idea jeremiah cragg since 1794.
that's good scotch 12 years josh
once again brother you've outdone us um
oh
good sibling rivalry here okay
wait no no no no no no we already did
that no no no don't touch the bottle
you've been two years sober you can't
touch it again hello
yes can i pick it up with r2 yes and
hannah you look so damn hot in that
shirt but i bet you're even
better out of it come to the guest room
at 2 am
love mike oh really so i'm just a piece
of meat and a nice shirt
how dare you mike i'm on the way right
now
what did our naive sister get herself
into now oh that's not for me i'm not
hannah okay
i have no idea who all these people are
i'm glad you can make it
yeah ah
what is that all about we should start
with a little you know
making out and see where it goes from
there
oh hell yeah no no
no cover it for the children no no no
it's just a prank
what
oh friends right guys are jerks
you know that that sounds like hayden
panetta panitaniri
panatonnery bye hannah we'll never see
you again apparently
oh no wait right stick to choose choose
what
what am i doing joss wake jess
josh you drunk bastard josh
josh josh
watch your language young lady guys
there's someone outside
oh i probably should have gone for the
others first i probably just already
made a bad decision
hannah what's going on where's my sister
going
it's fine she just can't take a joke it
was just a prank hand
it's just a prank what did you do we're
just messing around bad that wasn't
serious
you jerks anna
hannah so should we go after her
do i get to choose this too i think
you're the last person she wants to see
right
now mike
what oh god quick time events uh i swear
oh god i'm not good at this i don't know
the playstation controller that well
fast let's go fast i can do this ah i
got it i got it
oh i can't lose it now
come on
yes good idea go towards the murderer in
the woods
damn it hannah where are you
hey come back here hannah i just i saw
her
i i just i just saw her didn't see a
shadow though
i saw someone moving through the woods
though
uh oh god i gotta use this too holy crap
that's not okay
oh oh
i'm directing the flashlight hannah
hannah hannah
hannah oh [ __ ] jesus
god damn okay
walk faster why don't you run faster
lady
run faster in your sassy uggs hello
hello hello anybody
anybody oh what is that
that's weird why is this here
a death totem why was there a death
totem
that seems abnormal maybe i should be
concerned about that
this is so heavy rain inspired what was
that
i have no idea what's going on no idea
at all
i am so confused oh goodness
hi what the hell oh no perfectly normal
fireball is in the woods i shouldn't
worry about that
fireball's back at the cabin if you oh
hello
hi anna hannah oh my god you must be
freezing
here take my coat i'm such an idiot
i look so dumb that was quick
oh her face
[ __ ]
holy crap don't look at me oh no you
don't
wait ah let go let go gotta let go
bring this together hannah threw this
together
oh i made a bad choice
oh he was probably just a friendly
woodley fireman
oh i made a horrible choice
wow oh that was the worst choice i could
possibly make
before we begin there are a few things i
need to make sure you
understand you see no one can change
what happened last year past is beyond
our control
you have to accept this in order to move
forward
but there is freedom in this revelation
everything you do every decision you
make from now on will open
doors to the future i want you to
remember this i want you to remember
this as you play your game every single
choice
your fate and the fate of those around
you
hey okay just back up a little bit there
so you have committed to commence with
this game
this is significant you're in the i want
to help you see it through
sometimes sometimes these things can be
a little scary
even terrifying but i'm here to make
sure that no matter how upsetting things
may get
you will always find a way to work
through it i just
know all right
we will start with a simple exercise
could you please pick up carter i don't
think i want to and i want you to look
at the picture
on the other side and tell me what you
feel i feel that you're the creepiest
that you answer honestly in order to get
the most out of this experience
okay are you done there are multiple
reasons why this is all in the end no
you smile at me you weirdo what kind of
gloved weird hand am i
my mat i better not be matt
i feel creeped out about it why why do
you why do you do i need to
it's creepy as hell just like you so
how did that picture make you feel
remember be honest very creeped out i
don't like mannequins
you feel uneasy thank you very much okay
honestly
it's good don't even look at me you're
so weird it is that
makes you feel uneasy the scarecrow jeez
don't you don't do that the scarecrow
jesus
well i see i see let's see the scarecrow
were not there would you feel
comfortable staying there on your own
for a period of time
i'd say a week for example yeah sure it
looks nice besides the scarecrow
sure i would
is that where you're gonna send me and
what if i told you
that this cottage it's a barn
oh all right whatever i wouldn't care
haunted
so the scarecrow frightens you and yet
you don't appear to be bothered by the
possibility of the supernatural
your face is freaking supernatural dude
i suspect that
someone is not being entirely honest
with me that's that no just back up a
little that's what me
oh okay let's investigate that in our
next
session shall we no
i
do i should i go
you're just gonna we're just gonna sit
here okay we're just gonna sit here for
a bit
okay well that was the intro sequence
how about a whole bunch of that
that was fun oh boy i made a bad choice
and then i'm scared of a scarecrow
at least the music is pretty
are they singing about death it's all
very pretty music i hope i can keep it
in
i mean all these ah it was hannah
but hannah hayden panettieri hannah
paniterrarium
when god is
don't take this
today is the one year anniversary of the
dreadful tragedy that took place on
mount washington
was in charge of the investigation
thanks for having me marty this is an
update on hannah and beth washington the
twins who are still missing one year ago
tonight the washington girls left the
safety of their parents lodge and headed
out into a snowstorm
foul play not officially no there is one
individual we're considering as a person
of interest but his whereabouts are
currently unknown
he has an interesting history with the
washington family the guy with the blame
against pursuing their construction
projects and claimed the land was sacred
to his forefathers
my officers did search the grounds but
the girls themselves couldn't have made
it that far
something about that mountain seems to
breed tragic events more than you know
marty
well thank you for joining us with all
the washington's tonight
with their son josh on this the
anniversary of the mysterious
disappearance
of hannah and beth washington well hello
friends and fans all right let's do that
again
youtubers so all right well
hello friends and fans beyond
awesome to have you guys all back this
year could you stop some more first off
i gotta say i am super excited to
welcome all my pals back
to the annual blackwood winter getaway
so um let me just let you know uh let's
take a moment
to address the elephant in the room
for a second i know you're all probably
worried about me
and i know it's gonna be tough on all of
us going back
after what happened last year but
i just want you all to know um
it means it means so much to me
that we're doing this and that
i know it would mean so much to hannah
and beth that we're
we're all still here together and i'm
thinking of them
i really want to spend some quality time
with
each and every one of you and um just
share some moments that
we'll never forget for
for the sake of my sisters and you know
okay so let's party like we're [ __ ]
porn stars okay let's take this one trip
we will never forget all right yes
let's not do that i was feeling really
bad for him for a while there and then
he
wants to party like porn stars i don't
even know how porn stars party
they might be really low key and just
like reading and stuff
another
that's a really cool song man the
production qua
it's so weird coming from indie horror
games and coming to this with all its
amazing production quality
because it looks like a freaking movie
is what it is it is basically a freaking
movie
oh why is friendship in blood red
why and why is no one else here i wonder
why no one else showed up
oh boy so now i guess we're going to be
back hey
how's it going there hi friend oh it's
good that the bass drums are booming as
soon as i walk up into the haunted
forest i always like that one about that
ah okay delight diligent considerate and
adventurous
okay sam voiced by hayden pin and
anthony
hello hello someone there
maybe
the cable car station oh god i got to
walk through the woods all alone
why would i wear a skirt in the middle
of winter hello
i already know how to do that i've been
doing that since i
well maybe i don't know how to do that
because it caused two girls to fall to
their death
with my choices this is why i shouldn't
be given any sort of power because i
cannot make the right choices for
anybody
object link can be infected
the gates busted climb over chris how's
the gate busted
i already what how does it it's
it's a hinge yeah that's a stupid hinge
oh i'm so angry wait
oh that's the driver yo how do i get
here so
okay i guess i'm just gonna climb
rage against the machine this gate sure
is broken or something
oh okay no i was gonna strangle it
i'm so angry but i guess i'll just save
that for another day
liberty club let's go quick quick's a
good decision
i can make quick i can make quick happen
what
oh god no no no no i don't know the
buttons
jump
i won't know what happened if i were to
scrape my little knee or broken my spine
would have been terrible
i'm all in about that if i chose to go
with the flamethrower dude it probably
wouldn't have turned out so well for me
let's walk a little faster walk a little
faster now can i sprint can i run can i
jump
whoa what did i just do oh
i have character traits i could use a
bit more funny to be honest but okay
why do i have relationships with people
what the hell
oh that's so crazy
oh that's so crazy oh
that's i have no idea what any of that
means but i guess i'm gonna
i'm gonna do my hello fella
you hungry huh
i'm not moving i'm not moving i'm not
moving
cutie i win i want a squirrel
oh okay i'm guessing all this is still a
learning experience
so that i don't screw anything up
further now i'm beginning to wonder if
that
that choice in the beginning really
would change yeah i bet it would i bet
it did
i bet like there would have been some
other story arc of where the girl would
have gone with the guy and been
kidnapped in some regard or something or
other
butterfly prophecies i don't know how
cool you think that is but i don't think
it's very cool
tribes who once lived in these mountains
believed that butterflies carried dreams
and prophecies of possible futures the
color of the butterfly indicated the
nature of the prophecy
death black butterflies prophesies the
dreamer's death
danger is red loss is brown guidance is
yellow
fortune is white so white and yellow are
good
and black red and brown is bat is but
nine goot oh hello it's another totem
okay can i i'm tr i'm trying i'm
i'm i'm really reaching for it damn it
god damn it stop going into that
i'm i'm trying
okay so this is gonna really reveal a
premonition
birdie birdie
ah thanks for the guidance so that
said that there was gonna be a little
birdie by josh i think that josh is his
name
the future is uncertain whether or not
the prophecy comes true okay
our wonder view okay i already know that
button that is so pretty
where are they where are they that they
get this view
is that everest what does that say the
past is beyond our control
thanks thanks weird prophesizing
sign wow graffiti all the way up here
yep that's griffin
sanatorium at the top of the hill why
would there be a sanatorium at the top
of the hill
i'm pretty sure that's just an old word
for a mental hospital
where are you you're not in the bag are
you
in pieces uh-oh what do we have here
it's some weird kind of
telecommunication device
the likes of which i've never seen let's
snoop i'm a snoop
that was white that was good look who it
is
okay he knows it
chris
hi methodical protective and humorous
has a crush on ashley wait am i ashley
i'm no i'm sam are you my secretary
i was buzzing cool well thanks for
letting me know i
i can take it from here he had a text
from ashley
he had a text from ashley he's going to
get some ashley
maybe probably not cause things are
gonna go south so
i found something kind of amazing how
amazing
i'm not gonna tell you you gotta see for
yourself come on it's this way
okay right around here gonna blow your
mind
i don't like that i don't like the way
you said mind
mine should only have one syllable you
put like 13 on that sun [ __ ]
this don't look good who's wanted i saw
that hang on
oh man look at this
nice you think we'll get a visit from
america's most wanted
why would you want that someone thought
so why would you want that at all
god the way you smile in the darkness is
just the creepiest
yeah come on look at these beauties
beauties is not the word that comes to
mind why is this even here
what do you mean what the hell is a
shooting range doing at the base of a
ski lodge
uh dude have you ever met josh's dad
yeah don't point that at me grizzly
adams or something don't point that at
me wanna try
ah no you go ahead grizzly all right
get ready for the ace shack here goes
don't mind if i do
who am i going to shoot first
well oh uh
i'm sorry i'm used to call of duty
controls i can't believe this
oh i'm great oh what am i shooting at
here
oh look how great i is
i'm pretty terrible at these controls so
it's amazing that i'm hitting anything
at all
thanks i'm bad
don't do that don't stop that no no no
no
i don't think so girl yeah girl like
you'd know anything about this
girl well anybody and their brother
could shoot a bottle that big that close
oh we're talking about no i ain't
shooting that
no screw you i ain't doing it no
no no ain't no hell
hey shooting it
nice shot thanks you guys just got
sacked
just like these nuts sharpshooter our
ride's coming
okay so i got some more luck come on
chris the cable car
oh god i wonder who would choose to
shoot the squirrel that'd be so sad
how would that change the game that
probably has like the biggest effect on
the entire game
ever in the history of anything all
right
let's see i'm gonna get up the cable car
and then i'll end this episode here
god this game is so cool
it's definitely weird coming back up
here after a whole year could you
enunciate a little more a few more
consonants and syllables
here goes fast hmm
hey that's weird door's locked yeah
uh josh wanted us to keep it locked keep
people out he said that
what people i i don't know you said they
found people sleeping in the station one
time that's
creepy
were they murderers for you ah real
gentlemen
could you be any slower
trying to do a thing here trying to get
a game gone
trying to think of incredibly clever
commentary and it's not working
what else could i do and i thought the
car was closer
i guess we got to wait hotel and hotel
and sanatorium
am i not sure what a sanatorium is
please to set up house
no matter how rich you are yeah i only
bought a mountain i can buy a mountain
how do i buy a mountain some people buy
islands i want to buy a mountain
and then sit at the top of it and yell
at people but if someone makes it to the
top
then then i will grant them the gift of
my immense knowledge
maybe am i supposed to be looking at
something
oh is that the cable car okay okay
okay all right we're fine anything else
here
can i mumble my way over this way in
norwegian
i think there's something over here oh
i'm all explored out
better walk in circles samir hello sam
finally you coming yeah well i was gonna
stay here and catch some z's but
okay oh i'm so sassy and clever
it's not just me right this game is so
immensely heavy rain
like full on i hope i didn't miss
anything else
i probably would have seen something if
i would have gone back to maybe the the
the uh security camera and i would have
seen something adventure begins
oh i hope this was the right thing to do
what
you know getting everyone together on
the anniversary of course it was
josh seemed really pumped about us all
doing something didn't he
yeah no he definitely did i haven't seen
him so excited about something in
forever
good good it's hard to tell with him and
i
and i'm kind of worried no no it was it
was a good idea
i hope everyone else feels the same way
thanks bro good talk
are they you know what let's just let's
just stop talking about what happened
and enjoy the trip
ah you know what you're right you know
how josh and i met
no yeah but you're gonna tell me josh
sat in the back of the room
i sat in the front hmm we didn't even
know each other existed
but the kids sitting next to josh
started strap snapping the training bra
on the girl in front of him
so the teacher made him move to the
front where i was sitting
oh i got moved to the back and
and next to josh that's how we met yeah
became friends to this day made in
heaven
the fact that genie simmons hit puberty
like
three years earlier he decided to wear a
low-cut shirt that showed off her
training bra
i mean who knows you could be riding in
this cable car alone
right now or we're talking to some other
person entirely it's the
buyer's butterfly effect
called it called it man this game sure
likes the butterfly effect
i really wonder how many choices really
exist in this game
i really hope it's quite diverse because
that would be really cool if everyone
like makes different choice
i'm gonna try to make different choices
than what people would typically make
and i
confident trusting irreverent
i gotta remember what irreverent means
boy oh boy oh boy time to meet and greet
oh you're the new girlfriend that's
coming up on the anniversary of
the sister's death great time to mingle
okay hell jess hey jessica over here
uh are you guys having a really weird
stroke
we're stuck in this stupid thing can you
please let us out
pretty please okay
maybe maybe i won't oh
okay all right all right okay
oh my god i thought we were goners
another 10 minutes in there and i would
have chewed off my own leg
oh sick chris look i got a lot of meat
on my bones
this is all muscle down here yeah right
not up here though
it's like a twig up here but down there
thunder thighs for days like sam taught
me
other people's private thoughts or my
own personal
playground do not be a jerk my goodness
seems that someone has a little crush on
our good friend
and dear class president michael monroe
chris
and what kind of sizzling erotica might
our jessica be capable of imagining
i wonder
i'm a knight now mike and m split were
together
whoa drama pretty clear-cut actually
em's out i'm in
oh huh amazing people having real
relationships that's not drama filled to
fuel the story
what a wonder that hair looks really
good too all right
on the guy i'm just saying like the hair
effect is really good
also the hair's pretty good i'm just
gonna wait here for a bit
i'm gonna wait here for a little bit
this is my impression of this girl
i mean you know whoever what's your
name sam did you see this view
i mean holy cow yeah it's not creepy at
all
and take it all in this is what normal
humans do
when they're talking about things right
where the cable car ends
mike's ex intelligent resourceful and
persuasive but definitely not irreverent
i don't think it would have been like as
pretty
emily's new boyfriend oh i'm so moody
and handsome
motivated ambitious and active you know
and where's the bell boy when you need
one
there he is right there all right so i'm
gonna stop it
right there hello dude how you doing
looking good i'm gonna go over here so
it's a little less weird okay
what in the hell does that do what does
that do
i don't know what any of this is there's
a lot of words don't lick your lips i
see you in the background over there
so thank you everybody so much for
watching this is going to be a really
really
really interesting playthrough and we
will see what happens when we get to
these choices that we're gonna make
and how i fail at them all right cool
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think of this game
in the comments down below let me know
like if there's any special choices that
i need to make and i need to know about
i need to know about them so thank you
again
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
gotta become a marathon runner with all
the sprinting back and forth i'm doing
we're okay
4 am we're doing fine tonight